على هذه الحدود بين اوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا
قد يتخذ النزاع في اوكرانيا منحا تصعيديا
لا تحمد عقبه فعلى الجهه المقابله تتخذ
مينسك وموسكو اجراءات نوويه في سياق
التصيد الحاد للغايه لتهديدات على الحدود
الغربيه لروسيا وبيلاروسيا تم اتخاذ قرار
بشان القيام باجراءات في المجال النووي
العسكري
اجراءات البلدين التي تضمنت الاتفاق على
نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه فوق اراضي
بيلاروسيا تاتي بعد ايام قليله من هجوم
استهدف بيلجرود الروسيه لكن شايغو قال ان
الخطوه موجهه لمقاومه الغرب الذي يشن حربا
غير معلنه بشكل اساسي ضد روسيا وان النشاط
العسكري لحلف شمال الاطلسي قد اتخذ
الاتجاه الاكثر عدوانيه من جانبها اكدت
وزاره الدفاع البيلاروسيه التوقيع على
وثائق للاحتفاظ بالاسلحه النوويه الروسيه
غير الاستراتيجيه في تخزين خاصه على
اراضيها
ووفقا لوزير الدفاع الروسي فانه تم تسليم
القوات البيلاروسيه نظام الصواريخ
العملياتيه والتكتيكيه اسكندر ام الذي
يمكنه استخدام الصواريخ التقليديه
والنوويه على حد سوا اضافه لذلك فانه تم
اعاده تجهيز مقاتلات سوخه 25 للاستخدام
المحتمل للاسلحه النوويه وتحديد نظام وجود
منشاه خاصه لتخزين الاسلحه النوويه في
بيلاروسيا ايضا ومع ان موسكو ترى ان
الاجراءات تتم وفقا للالتزامات الدوليه
ولا تنتهك معاهده عدم انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه الا ان الانباء تقول ان الصراع
بدا ياخذ تصعيدا خارج الحدود الاوكرانيه
والروسيه وتهديدا نوويا رايت المصطفى
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات